salut c'est cyrus et si je suis ici
c'est pas prendre coup de fil c'est pour
vous remercier parce que vous êtes plus
de 5000 abonnés sur la chaîne donc je
trouve ça vraiment très stylé je suis
très content j'ai pas mal de retours
positifs aussi donc très encourageant et
des gens qui qui ont lu des ouvrages de
philo après les vidéos et à des profs de
philo qui montre les vidéos en cours un
bref c'est génial c'est génial et du
coup je voulais vous remercier
en répondant à vos questions de
philosophie des questions philosophiques
l'on peut se poser
je ne suis que ça pourrait être sympa si
j'ai essayé d'y répondre en tout cas
qu'on en discute ensemble
donc du coup j'ai posté cette vidéo sur
facebook et dans les commentaires du
post de la vidéo vous posez vos
questions
et moi je ferai une autre vidéo où je
répondrai à vos questions donc du coup
cette vidéo elle est un peu éphémère je
voulais a laissé quelques semaines le
temps d'avoir à cette question et et
puis je ferai une vidéo réponses pour
vous remercier
voilà merci encore du love et de la
piste